Okay.
So as far as the names Zack and Zoë Sweet
Bee Farm -
Zack and Zoe.
So we found out
that Zachary had allergies.
We were in Brooklyn visiting my husband's
sister in Williamsburg,
and we ordered Thai food.
We found out that they had tree
nut and peanut allergies
the hard way.
When it comes to seasonal allergies,
just growing up...
it wasn't like a huge detriment,
but it was just rough
just in the spring, always
just like having to stay inside, sorta
just hunker down.
Couldn’t play as much like sports
and things that I wanted to.
But honey just kind of change all that.
The honey is acting
as an anti-inflammatory agent and calming
all the inflammation down
at the same time.
It was really my dad's idea
to start actually keeping bees
and just having them in the backyard.
At first it was just like
we were buying them.
My dad has a mentor that we used
to get honey from all the time,
just like hey, and just switched
gears like,
this could be our own thing,
we can keep our own bees.
So we got some bees from him.
Just set up in the backyard,
and it's just been having more
and more hives ever since.
Thought it would be exciting
because living out here,
you get a real opportunity
to like build your own kind of farm.
When we started beekeeping, we had no idea
that there would be so many,
or so much honey, we really got an excess.
So we gave it out to friends and family
and then we said, you know what, next year
let's start a little business
with the children.
They'll learn how to have a business
and the ins and outs of that
since Dad's a business man,
we got these little labels going.
Started to sell it online a bit.
Eventually we thought,
Well, let's make it a little more serious.
Ended up being really, really a good idea.
We went to some artisanal markets
and started to sell the honey
and it really took off.
Is that small enough? I hope so.
It doesn’t have to be a full thing.
Stuff this....lot of smoky stuff.
That's not...
Okay. Yeah.
Okay. Oh, see, how it...
Yeah, that's perfect.
Yeah.
That's actually a perfect like,
not too much.
Not too little.
So when you're out beekeeping,
you need four things.
You need your bee suit,
you need a hive tool,
you need the smoker
and you need the bee brush.
Basically, the smoker tricks
the bees into thinking there's a fire,
so they're more focused on that situation
than you going into the hive
and taking the honey.
We approach the hive as a team,
so one person will usually be smoking
and the other will use the hive tool
and lift up the beehives.
And so we definitely need to communicate
with each other, that's one thing.
If you're beekeeping by yourself, then
make sure you have both of those ready.
Just be alert
and attentive to what the bees are doing.
Bees are pollinators, right?
So bees will typically
they eat pollen from the plant.
They also eat the nectar
and they go in, ingest that
with kind of enzymes in their own body
in that they reproduce honey.
So that honey is a food source
for the bees.
It's a food source for their young ones.
They’ll eat the honey,
but they'll also store it and save it
as their food source for the wintertime.
I mean, it's
literally hundreds of types of of honey,
depending on the floral source.
You've got honey
that's got more of a blueberry honey
that pollinate the blueberry groves
or the cranberry bogs, even,
you know, honey
bee pollinate in the California almonds
has a different like a more of a nuttier,
you know, profile
than, you know, honey, that is just a
more more of a floral source.
And so it really is
fascinating to understand
and just taste the different notes
and to see, you know, all honey is not the
same.
And so it's really cool
to see people experience it.
Once you go into the hive, you've taken
off all the protective coverings.
There's about nine frames in each box.
And so you're going to remove a frame
to harvest the honey.
And we're just taking out one
for breakfast tomorrow.
And so when you take the frame out,
you just make sure that
there's honey on it, first of all, in
that it's not a frame
that might have babies in it, brood,
they call it.
When there's honey,
they'll have little capsules over it.
So you'll see the same sort
of hexagon pattern
where there's honey
or whether without honey.
But when there's no honey there,
they're just not, you won’t
see the little cap over it,
which is where the honey’s stored.
So like us, the bees are storing up food
for the winter.
And here in North America, essentially,
that's an important part of their day.
They're thinking about how to make sure
they have enough for the queen,
the whole hive, the brood,
just to make it through the winter.
So you don't want to take too much honey
when you're harvesting,
you want to make sure they have enough
food to make it through
to the next warm season.
When you’re brushing the bees off
to get your honey..
just brush them back into the hive,
you know, just down
motion and straight back in.
So they don't have to get like confused
or dazed.
I'll just be right back where they belong
and just make sure they're none left.
You don’t want
just like one last bee around your house.
Yeah, expect one or two to follow
you home.
Beekeeping is just as easy as it is
that you're brave.
So if you want, honey,
all you have to do is have some courage
and enjoy yourself.
At first, I thought mixing superfoods
with the honey would be really strange
and it wouldn't really take off.
But once Ma tried it,
it tasted amazing and everyone
we sold it to really,
really loved the idea.
I would go to the organic markets
and when I would look at the shelves
I was like, How are we going to fit?
To stand out I just said,
Well, let's add matcha, let's add,
you know, raspberries, let's add ginger.
And yeah, lavender is a big one.
The hot honey just came out last year.
Oh, cardamom
if you haven't tried the cardamom,
it's just like...
by the spoonful.
But, yeah, there's plenty of options
that you can choose from.
There's, like 23 right now.
Once you bring a frame in, there's
something called an extractor
and so you have a big barrel,
and then inside
there's just something that spins
the darn honey right out of there.
All the honey just goes to the bottom
of the whole machine.
It goes right into the barrel. With a tap.
Yeah, with the tap on it and those barrels
go to our production studio.
We bring the honey in from the trucks
and we take the lids off, stir it up,
make sure they're nice and settled
and mixed properly.
Then we take them
and put them into the reservoir.
The machine holds the honey
and then it's pumped up
into a larger machine
where the superfoods are added.
And that's where the magic happens.
Then just, the employees
come and jar them very easily,
and we're able to label them
in the labeling machine,
put them in the box,
and then they're ready to go.
So everything you get
is just really literally that honey
and that organic superfood.
And that's the only process really
that we have going there.
So a lot of the honey
goes out to direct to consumer, others
go to larger retailers,
but a portion of it goes to Chelsea Market
where we're able to sell it face to face.
The best part about Chelsea
is just everything,
but the neighborhood is
what we were so excited about.
And having a spot
there is like has been epic for us.
Interacting with the customers, people
all over the world, an amazing experience.
So we bring in the honey as a family.
We have a good time with it.
So and we have an amazing team
that works there too.
People have said to us like your,
you know, workers are so sweet
and I’m like it’s the honey.
You guys, this is Zach and Zoë,
from Zach and Zoë’s farm.
Made my day!
You guys are cuter than your picture.
After that,
we just make sure that the customers
are satisfied
and everything is running smoothly.
And at the end of the day,
if everyone has their honey,
then we're good to go.
The kids have literally grown up
with bees, and so, it's fun
because as they get older, I mean, Zach is
14, Zoë is 15, going to be 16 next week.
As they get more independent,
you miss the moments, and the times
you spent with them.
And so it's a little, little bittersweet.
I mean, you're you're happy to see your
kids grow up, but you certainly miss them.
And you miss the memories
and you miss them putting on the bee
suits, or holding a smoker for dad
or bringing me the the hive tool.
So, you know, hopefully right,
when they get older and get married,
their kids want to come spend time
with grandpa doing bee work.
So we'll see.
When the business started,
it began to become tied with my upbringing
and even before I felt like that
we were prepared
to be raised into this business
and we were equipped with the skills
to keep the business running forward
even after like mom and dad eventually
like retire. I don't know.
You don't seem like the type to retire.
She keeps saying
can say, I'm never going to,
but yeah, I'm really, really grateful
for that,
that we have something that has set us up
for some serious
success. Aww
It's a lot to have a business with
your name on it, just like a big deal.
And I like thank Mom and Dad, of course,
because they did most of the heavy
lifting.
Obviously, you can't really run a business
when you're seven, but
it's definitely just a huge thing that’s
like just a kind of a part of me now.
I like pitch in, help.
Just something on my mind, I’m
always thinking about it,
what's new and like
what's coming up over the horizon.
But it's like a
just a nice state of mind to be in,
just like hey, like this is my own thing.
And then this is like eventually
I have to just carry on on my own like,
they can't run the business forever,
so like this is going to be my own thing
in the future, which is a big deal for me.